when I first set my eyes on a stylish
boss rush game fury I was sold by its
striking presentation and excited about
its mix of twin-stick shooting and
swordplay two of my favorite forms of
combat in games fury pits you against
just under a dozen bosses most of whom
are relentless strong and fast they
don't just have one health bar they have
multiple each one representing a new and
more challenging phase of combat armed
with an energy pistol a sword and the
ability to - you have to fight bosses
that turn invisible bosses that
automatically generate protective
barriers and bosses that emit dense and
chaotic waves of bullets most stages are
small circular arenas but there are
other locations that bend the rules
introducing a web of platforms are
shifting to a 2d plane
variety aside few battle stages are
memorable but the landscapes you try to
cross between battles leave an
unmistakable impression they are barren
weird encoded in neon presented through
dramatic and occasionally unsettling
camera angles piri is a beautiful game
one upping itself from one scene to the
next but there are times when you're
surreal hikes overstay their welcome and
your thirst for combat breeds temporary
impatience cutscenes can't match the
thrill of fighting
battles encompass two types of fighting
free roaming in an arena and close
quarters within a small circular
boundary while free roaming you play
fury like a twin stick shooter where the
direction of your movement is
independent from the trajectory of your
guns bullets though you're gonna liaos
you to attack enemies from afar they're
only vulnerable at certain times often
in the middle of an action that
ultimately produces an attack you have
to avoid or if you're quick enough with
your sword deflect back
so you fire your gun and dance out of
harm's way but when a boss rushes up for
a melee attack you only have two options
- away or try to parry their attack -
and you may be safe but you're doing
yourself a disservice to succeed at fury
is to master the art of carrying and
anything less will almost certainly
guarantee failure in later stages
before an enemy issues a parable attack
they will flash for an instant logic
tells you that you should press the
parry button during the flash but in
practice the timing feels somewhat loose
no one said this was supposed to be fair
said one of my nemesis she was right and
there were times that I felt fury was
unfair times when I needed an excuse for
failure despite being difficult fury
gives you all the tools you need to
succeed from the very beginning and
while the odds are in the favor of your
opponents it's the point they don't call
them bosses for nothing
so the pace and rhythm of each boss is
melee attacks change when you establish
a subconscious alignment with Fury's
timing you feel at home in combat
without that skill success is now
impossible to enjoy fury is to
understand it a process that may involve
repeated failure and in turn frustration
however once you attain the ability to
deflect attacks and punish your opponent
with confidence any feeling that Fury's
bosses are unfair just discipline upon
completing the game a bumpy process that
took almost ten hours I felt
accomplished but I didn't feel like my
work was finished I couldn't help but
start the game over
I had improved both in terms of skill
and knowledge I knew how each boss
behaved and how to counter their most
punishing attacks my second time through
the game I had the advantage and with my
newfound confidence I was an efficient
killer not desperate prey and I beat the
game in just over two hours without
dying despite having seen it all before
fury transformed as I had transformed
and what was once too difficult felt
just right
fury is a beautiful game and one that
lures you in with a cool lead character
and a powerful soundtrack these
qualities are easy to appreciate but
it's the journey to become a better
fighter that defines the experience
theory will make you sweat under
pressure scream in frustration but it
will also give you the drive to get
better to become a boss of your own once
you do there's almost no feeling legged